i want to know what you would take like
if there was a fire raging
through this home what are the absolute
necessities that you would
that are very dear to your heart that
you look like how much time do you have
how much time yeah 10 minutes okay so
i wake up fire right yeah at first these
because branding branding no no no it's
not that it's just that because
um i just like them a lot okay do they
have sentimental value
they have sentimental values i put the
gucci glasses on you know because i like
them
also to protect your eyes from the heat
right i would have to get
clothes on because i don't want to be on
fire and running on the street naked
yeah
right so i would get like my favorite
pair of um raw denims
i would get my favorite pair of golden
goo shoes okay you know what i mean i
would probably take about 10 shirts
jules and i are still asleep at this
point yeah but this is what i'm doing
because i want to
because i know what you're going to do
if i wake you up what i have to do what
you want to do so i got to do it
take the i know i'm gonna do that i'm
gonna do that
i'm gonna do it but let me just do
forgot about that don't look at how
angry she is
are you angry no no go ahead i i wanna
know your soul bury your soul uh
yeah but also this is this is only going
to take
40 seconds mind you okay getting the
shirt i mean
i think 40 okay all right so you know i
have nine minutes have passed
then okay i mean sorry nine minutes left
yeah yeah okay a minute pass
i have my glasses on i have all my
clothes on right yeah
and they're like sweetie and you wake up
and i go
fire yeah is that how you would say it
[ __ ] question mark fire
right and then you'd wake jewels up
right and then
the next four minutes is the the four
months of hell
yeah is trying to wrangle the animals
the cats are
the cats are the hardest right um i
might leave one of them
what i'm sorry i have to i have to
that's a lot of animals you will
[ __ ] wait i already have a
contingency plan for this stuff
okay so then what do we do i practice i
i i do i run drills at home with myself
yeah
she's like ben still in the movie the
royal tennis ball i am that's exactly
who i am actually so like i run
like drills in my head like i know
exactly where their crates are
like where to corner like because cats
get spooked and when they
when they're spooked it doesn't matter
if they love you they'll just want to
bolt
so i know where all their crates are i
don't have
one crate i have three crates one each
for one
cat she does so the cat's in the dogs
all right now we have five minutes left
what do we do
um i'm asking you like what are things
in this home that you absolutely value
all the clubs the human beings no
besides the human beings and the animals
now
okay aside from that okay then i would
probably go um
you got four minutes i need my phone and
my ipad okay good good
yeah i got to get that um i need my
cigarettes
i'll ask two i would smoke two a day but
i just need you
because it's stressful you can buy those
it doesn't matter i i need
you know what i mean and if i can't find
my lighter i'll just use the house fire
what about getting here
stick a cigarette into the house
[Laughter]
and then um i would get that and then um
other than that i think that's it i'm
out of the house
ipad the humans the animals yeah right
your wallet my favorite clothes my
yeah my wallet that's it and then i
would be out of the house i have five
minutes to spare
and then i would call what do you call
9-1-1 or 4-1-1 what do you do for 4-1-1
you call 4-1-1
call 4-1-1 right and go you know what i
mean
hello fire fire
i'll go fight sir is there a fire fire
yeah
oh i'd probably uh wake up the neighbors
how you how are you gonna wake up our
neighbor to the left
joe yeah i would knock on his door
not probably not yeah yeah probably not
i wouldn't i wouldn't wake up the
neighborhood they should know they
should smell the smoke
yeah yeah and then we would probably
back the car out of the driveway a
little bit
yeah get all everything in there and
then we would go to like a four seasons
or something
or we'll tell you there's actually one
thing i'm surprised you didn't take what
me too i'm not going to say it i'm not
going to say it
it's right next to you there's no time
to play
what dude right next to you
your father's ashes babe there's no
potential to play at my playstation
i can go to the next day i can go to
[ __ ]
best buy and go buy a whole new yeah to
be fair though that's already been burnt
yeah this right here so it's just i have
no idea first okay i want to say this
okay uh-oh
but what it's real yeah
this is a symbol i have no idea what's
in here maybe you're going to let him
die twice
yeah i mean is there oh there is nothing
there is not what if my dad's in him
[Laughter]
this wouldn't be in my forefront of my
mind because he's already passed
you know this to me this is just a
symbol but um
if i had time maybe i would grab that
you know and maybe that tiger belly neon
sign
[Laughter]
i like that other than that you know you
know it would be sad because
you know a lot of these um all these
little things
that's on the walls and in these
cupboards and all that stuff are things
i've collected over the years
and they have you know i'm not a hoarder
but i have deep um
you know emotional attachment to a lot
of things
because of memories and whatnot you know
um so it would be really a sad thing if
we were in a fire
yeah yeah you know with with me like i
don't
hold a single valley can you guys
believe this
not a single valuable piece of jewelry
except for bobby's um drug ring
yeah she has my drug ring where is it i
haven't seen it oh i have it
okay yeah i keep it nice and you know
secure but i'm just saying besides that
because i don't wear
um fancy jewelry at all like i don't own
a single like
gold anything nothing yeah well i think